we're just a couple weeks away from flu
season the prediction it actually could
be worse than in past years Victoria
Saha explaining why doctors want to be
very proactive about it
first flews in without coveted
precautions meaning no masks and no
social distancing which in the last
couple of years may have helped our flu
season according to the CDC for the
2021-2022 flu season up to 13 million
people suffered from flu illnesses but
for the 2018-2019 flu season 29 million
Americans got the flu so I think that's
why with the looser restrictions
especially in the state of Nevada I
think we're expecting a higher number
this year Dr Shivan Chaudhary an
internal medicine physician says
reflecting on Australia's recent flu
season is a good indicator of what's to
come in the United States which is why
getting the flu vaccine this year is a
good preventative measure so the CDC
points that they've changed the
composition of the type of you know the
vaccine that they've prepared so that's
number one different and also the CDC is
recommending for anyone that's older
than 65 years of age they have a higher
dose that they will need for you know
protection against the influenza virus I
mean is Nevada putting out a warning
saying Australia has already surpassed
200 000 flu cases Dr Chaudhary also says
those suffering from long-haul coveted
symptoms could also be more susceptible
to getting the flu Victoria Saha 8 News
Now